un anniversaire derrière les barreaux ce
samedi le co fondateur de wikileaks
julian assange fêtera ses 50 ans dans la
prison de belmarsh à londres pour cette
semaine particulière ses soutiens ont
organisé une campagne nommée assange
week afin de dénoncer sa détention alors
que le frère et le père du lanceur
d'alert sont actuellement campagne en sa
faveur aux états unis sa compagne se
mobilisent au royaume uni pour rappeler
la situation du journaliste à l'opinion
publique chaque fois que je vois
jolienne ici c'est difficile de vraiment
comprendre comment tout ça peut encore
durer
julien est un prisonnier politique au
royaume uni il est incarcéré depuis plus
de deux ans et il aura 50 ans samedi
la dernière fois que je vienne a été un
homme libre il avait la trentaine
il avait 39 ans lorsqu'il est venu dans
ce pays sur invitation du guardian ce
mardi elle est venue manifester devant
la prison de belles marches accompagné
de parlementaires travaillistes
britanniques plus de 20 membres du
parlement ont signé une lettre à
l'attention du directeur de la prison
ils exigent de rencontres et de julian
assange nous sommes ici aujourd'hui pour
attirer l'attention sur le fait que nous
devrions pouvoir rendre visite à julian
et prendre conseil auprès de lui en tant
que membre élu de notre parlement
jusqu'à présent cela nous a été refusé
mais nous allons continuer à le demander
mais plus que tout poursuivons cette
campagne et veillons à ce que julian ne
soit pas tout bonnement extradé vers les
états unis ou ailleurs mais qu'ils
soient libérés afin qu'ils puissent être
avec sa compagne ses enfants et être à
nouveau en homme libre
julian assange est incarcéré depuis
avril 2019
d'abord à la demande de la justice
suédoise puis des états unis qui
l'accusent d'avoir diffusé des documents
classifiés sur des activités militaires
américaines
il risque une peine de 100 75 ans de
prison s'il est extradé en janvier
dernier la justice britannique a annoncé
son refus de l'expulser outre atlantique
une décision contestée par
l'administration maiden qui a fait appel
au mois de février
le cofondateur de wikileaks reste depuis
dans la tente de la décision
cour d'appel